hey we're here in las vegas for CES now
the big show starts tomorrow but we're
going to go into a press preview event
and show you some of the coolest things
that you'll see at the big show you know
those pretentious people who are always
walking around with their super light
super expensive MacBook Airs well check
this out here's a super light windows
machine from MSI and it will only cost
seven hundred to a thousand dollars when
it comes out later this year probably in
April now we don't know too much about
this other than its weight which is
about two and a half pounds and it's
probable price but hey 700 bucks what
more do you need to know take that fat
cats check out who I just met this is
wow he's newest toy robot he's called
Joe ba and he's a sassy wisecracking
dancing robot with lots of attitude and
in a new development for a while we he's
also voice-controlled unfortunately a
voice doesn't carry too well in a noisy
environment like this conference room
but you can also control him through
simple hand gestures so I'm going to
wiggle his hand here whoa like I said
he's got a lot of attitude he'll be
coming out later this year and he will
cost just about a hundred dollars or
maybe even less here's a cool thing we
found at the CES preview this is a
secure hard drive from Lenovo and it's
got a little keypad on the front and the
reason that that's there is because all
the data on this hard drive is stored in
an encrypted form and you can only
access it after you plug it into your
computer by entering the correct
passcode and that can be anywhere from
six to 20 digits how's that for security
this is a thinkpad w700 d/s it's a high
powered laptop aimed at graphics
professionals and it's got a little bit
extra
namely a whole second screen that pops
out of the side of the first one like a
little mini sidekick as if this 16 inch
screen weren't big enough for you you've
got a little 10 inch screen over here
that you can use to put your palates
from Photoshop or if you want you could
put Twitter over there and keep an eye
on what your friends are up to the
computer is incredibly high powered it's
got a quad-core processor and video
graphics and it looks like it's got two
of just about everything there's a
little red track point mouse down here
in the middle of the keyboard as well as
a touchpad there's even a digitizer
tablet here for you graphics wonks there
even to enter keys check it out to blue
enter keys all this computing power is
going to cost you though the w700 DS
goes for thirty-five hundred dollars and
up high tech gumdrop rocket nose cone
actually none of the above this is a
wireless speaker for your ipod from the
sharper image the company you might know
better as having gone into bankruptcy
and close all their stores last year
well the company is back and now they're
making electronics under their own brand
name and selling them in stores like
best buy or maybe even Nordstrom and
here's an example this is one of their
first products you plug the ipod into
the docking station and then you can
take the two speakers up to a hundred
and fifty feet away and listen to your
tunes put this anywhere you want next to
the pool next to your mai tai you name
it it's even got its own little volume
control on the bottom a little dial so
that you can adjust the volume to
whatever you want now check this out
sharper image used to be known for
overpriced things like hundred-dollar
nose hair trimmers this is going to be a
hundred and thirty bucks not bad for a
wireless ipod speaker system